upcoming is absolutely no surprise to
anybody
donald trump is issuing a directive that
his lawyer rudy giuliani not be paid for
his work
on election fraud so-called election
fraud for donald trump and
this is not um surprising to anybody
there are still questions as to whether
trump was completely serious or only
partially serious when he said this
but it's it's sort of ironic in a sense
because at the very beginning of all of
this we heard
oh rudy giuliani is billing 20 grand a
week to fight this
completely fruitless pointless bogus
fight uh over so-called voter fraud for
donald trump
but just because he wants 20 grand a
week a day just because he submits a
bill for 20 grand a day to donald trump
doesn't mean that he's going to get
necessarily
paid and we suspected that because
donald trump has a very very long
history
of not paying his vendors and we've
heard before from
would-be or former trump lawyers that
they want clients who pay
their legal bills and so now uh
once again apparently irritated with
being impeached a second time which
happened two days ago and we discussed
it yesterday
donald trump has told people stop paying
rudy giuliani's legal fees
um trump i i actually don't really even
know what the connection is that trump
believes exists between him and peach
the second time
and rudy giuliani rudy giuliani was
fighting the bogus fight
that trump hired him to fight and
rudy giuliani did speak and talk about
trial by combat at that completely
misguided rally on wednesday morning on
january 6th
but it was really trump who said let's
go to the capitol and
incited that riot so i don't even know i
don't even understand the connection
between trump being irritated with rudy
over the second impeachment but as we
know donald trump is unable to take any
responsibility
himself and blames people around him
and uh the reports are that he's blaming
a lot of people in his inner circle inc
including rudy giuliani and others for
the predicament he finds himself in
and at a certain point it may be as
simple with trump as i blamed them
because they didn't prevent me from
doing the things i did
and saying even though i did them it's
really someone else's fault because
someone else
i hired other people to prevent me from
getting into this kind of trouble
i don't know a trump campaign senior
advisor jason miller sort of
said trump is not soured on giuliani
but when he was more directly asked is
trump directing giuliani not to be paid
jason miller did not deny that he said i
just spoke with president trump
and he told me rudy giuliani is a great
guy and a patriot
who devoted his services to the country
we all love america's mayor
but no denial whatsoever of the
allegation that donald trump is saying
do not pay
rudy giuliani one other aspect of this
john eastman
is this conservative attorney you might
remember his name we talked about him i
believe it's only once before on the
show
john eastman falsely told trump mike
pres
mike president vice pence vice president
mike pence
uh could block the certification of joe
biden's win that was not true
and we are now hearing rumors that john
eastman might join donald trump's legal
team what the point of a legal team is
in the last
five days of the presidency i don't know
but these are just preliminary
discussions uh
what would be the plan there and
this again would go towards this idea
that trump if you can tell trump what he
wants to hear
you get yourself into his inner circle
and this is
arguably why trump's press secretary
kelly mcinanni
uh has has lasted as long as she has
lasted because she has shown
an unfettered unm unmitigated
willingness
to repeat any lie for donald trump
and to defend any action by donald trump
never ceding an inch never conceding
anything
and that's what trump wants and so now
reportedly john eastman
has some ideas of things trump could do
what they are i don't know
and there are rumors that with just five
days left in donald trump's presidency
he may be joining he may be joining
donald trump's team
for what uh some are calling a
a challenging chapter yes
that is certainly an understatement and
trump increasingly isolated and
desperate to find
anybody that will indulge his wackiest
and wildest notions
we're down to just a few days my friends
just a few days to go and then he will
be gone at least officially
but we will see to what degree donald
trump remains in the public eye
we have a great show for you today make
sure you're following me on twitter at
deepakman
we will take a break and have a
fantastic program for you coming up
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade
single origin arabica coffee with
both lion's mane and chaga mushrooms
chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer-reviewed studies i've been
drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video